tonight we take a closer look at where
the migrant children
are staying along the border
correspondent steve harrigan is in donna
texas tonight
the customs and border facility at donna
texas has gotten attention for all the
wrong reasons
overcrowding and keeping some
unaccompanied minors too long
children are supposed to be transferred
to health and human services run
shelters
within 72 hours but when shelter space
is limited
children can get stuck in border
detention centers for longer periods
as is happening now some texas state
senators estimate the growing cost
at one thousand dollars per day per
child
and these are federal policies that draw
on
our state but we do it
because we value human life in the state
of texas
major construction is now going on
around the clock in a scramble to house
unaccompanied minors
aged 17 and under who've crossed the
border into the u.s
without parents and without any legal
immigration status
under the biden administration the
unaccompanied minors are not
subject to deportation the stated goal
is to house them safely
and reunite them with family members in
the u.s as quickly as possible
so far arrivals far outnumber beds
seventeen thousand unaccompanied minors
are on pace to arrive in texas
this month alone a second facility here
will hold
only 500. the military is now being
asked to house children in fort bliss
texas
and joint base san antonio the pentagon
says they are ready to help
the military's role was to provide the
site
and as i said there may be some some
contracting support that we offer
but it's not to provide for care or
supervision
of the of the children a local
non-profit director here said he was
first asked to supply
three meals a day for two hundred
children
those figures quickly changed first to
two thousand children
then three thousand eight hundred the
numbers here keep rising
brett steve harrigan in downtown texas
steve thanks